[Musique]
je me trouve à La Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet pour la finale régionale
d'Île-de-France du meilleur jeune berger
ils sont à peu près une quinzaine de
candidats de la Bergerie Nationale à
passer ce concours ils ont plusieurs
épreuves à passer en va découvrir
lesquels ensemble est-ce que elle me
tourne le dos est-ce qu'un petit mot
pour
[Musique]
la belle je vais faire la
l'état de santé donc ça consiste à
évaluer l'état de santé de la brebis
donc on va regarder à l'arrière les
dents les paupières qu'on regarde l'état
santé générale de l'animal
vu qu'elle est à l'air elle doit
sûrement avoir attrapé une
diarrhée donc à surveiller on surveille
au niveau de la Corporelle de l'animal
ça doit être à combien normalement à
température
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as choisi ce métier là parce
que j'aime bien être en extérieur j'aime
bien j'aime bien faire tout le temps
quelque chose de différent j'aime pas la
routine c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose de plutôt complet et j'adore les
animaux
[Musique]
et je me trouve avec Manon Batista
ancienne élève de la Bergerie Nationale
qui avait participé aux Olympiades
l'année dernière qui est maintenant
bergère à la Bergerie Nationale alors
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça fait
maintenant d'être jury bah c'est une
satisfaction personnelle parce que c'est
vrai que participer à un concours comme
ça et puis faire les Olympiades
nationales et maintenant jugé c'est vrai
que c'est une concrétisation c'est c'est
cool c'est compliqué de juger maintenant
ou alors qu'avant tu faisais les
épreuves pas tant que ça je dirais même
que c'est presque plus facile parce que
je sais ce que ça fait d'être en face et
alors Anne Séverine François vous l'avez
formée pareil c'est une fierté pour vous
de l'avoir évolué et devenir bergère oui
bien sûr maintenant je l'ai suivi donc
pendant son BTS et des années de BTS
l'an dernier je l'ai accompagné aux
Olympiades jusqu'au salon de
l'agriculture et maintenant j'ai la
chance de travailler avec elle donc
c'est bah c'est toujours plaisant en
fait de déjà de voir que ces élèves
réussissent et puis après de réussir à
travailler avec eux
[Musique]
et les deux meilleures candidats de
cette finale régionale pourront
participer à la finale nationale du
meilleur jeune berger elle aura lieu au
salon de l'agriculture fin février
[Musique]